j'en enfin là justement avec notre
reporter nadège abderrazak elle est sur
place nadal bonjour alors quelle est
l'ambiance actuellement écoutez amira
ils sont plusieurs dizaines de
manifestants à avoir répondu à l'appel
un des organisateurs de cette opération
ouvre et les cinémas alors ce dimanche
14 mars
on célèbre un triste anniversaire
puisque cela fait un an maintenant que
la première fermeture des cinémas a été
actée déclaré dans le cadre de la crise
sanitaire et sur cette dernière année on
déplore deux cent quarante quatre jours
de fermeture des salles obscures
jamais les cinémas ont été fermés aussi
longtemps dans l'histoire même pas
pendant les guerres mondiales alors ce
que demandent ces manifestants présents
ici eh bien c'est la réouverture
immédiate des salles de cinéma le
directeur de ce cinéma le trianon ici à
romainville cinéma est classé monument
historique se dit même prêt à mettre en
place un protocole sanitaires strictes
je vous propose de l'écouter les études
partout dans le monde ont démontré qu'il
n'y a eu aucun cas de contamination par
la coved 19 qui a été déclaré dans un
cinéma on accole sanitaire qui aurait
connu comme étant un des plus strictes
et un des plus compatibles de dire avec
le la propagation de l'épidémie
donc
ici la salle fait 420 places on a moyen
même en réduisant encore les jauges
d'accueillir le public dans
d'excellentes conditions sanitaires
cette fermeture des salles de cinéma et
jugeait illogique et incompréhensible
pour de nombreux manifestants qui ont
tenu à témoigner à notre micro
c'est quand même pas normal que j'ai à
dire qu'ils se seraient pas ouverts
alors que bon les commerces sont ouverts
même s'ils ont revu leur petit peu
différemment mais voilà ça serait bien
qu'ils rouvrent d'autant plus que bon
faut pas responsable par rapport à la
situation si quelqu'un est responsable
donc parce que moi je pense que c'est le
gouvernement anc a manqué un seul par
rapport aux masques par rapport au gel
par rapport à vaccination
on arrive patients vaccinés est bon ce
qui paye je suis allé au cinéma cet été
et il y avait des normes de sécurité qui
était tout à fait respecté avec le
masque avec l'espacement dans les dents
les sièges dont vous je vois pas
pourquoi c'est pas réouvert moi
personnellement je suis enseignant je
fais court tous les jours a entre 25 et
75 enfants qui portent le masque etc en
droit de le faire pas cinéma me manque
énormément comme et à aucune activité
plus rien donc
et puis pour se tenir aussi les
intermittents du spectacle tous le monde
de la culture
c'est vrai tout est fermé ça nous manque
énormément
l'appel à la réouverture des salles de
cinéma et des lieux culturels plus
généralement sera-t-il entendu par le
gouvernement
un rien n'est moins sûr pourquoi et bien
parce que la situation sanitaire se
dégrade de jour en jour que le nombre de
contaminations qu'ovide 19 explose et
que l hypothèse d'un confinement d'un
troisième confinement dur proposé évoqué
au au mois de janvier bien se fait de
nouveau insistante aujourd'hui
merci un manager pour toutes ces
précisions